I'm gonna get smell from jogo haven't
set up any of this on this view yet so
it should be interesting
oh god I have to sneeze so we only get
glad jail fw3 think we're going to see
Mako I have seen Meg already nope I
don't we're gonna get get to see Meg
so if you're watching you're gonna learn
how to get get started with C++
programming and OpenGL so you can like
make games custom how you want not using
any engine make their own engine to make
your own logic and all that stuff it's
pretty much what I want to show I'm
gonna eat cheese while doing it
you like cheese we're gonna kill it all
64-bit stuff if we can manage to
probably this over here there we go my
defaults you make does not add structure
to the system Pat mmm I don't know I'm
not sure what am i doing there let's
share a beer shall we
Swain's don't see make right pin it to
my starter dad
all right so yeah I guess that's first
the first step here is to make that's
easy you know we need glad so we're
gonna look up glad wasn't delighted glad
oh that's not what we're talking about
though see if we can find it
glad Heather yeah it's an OpenGL thing
by this guy this is what we're actually
looking for this will link here well
you should get tab over and low thing
but you could that's fine
come on boys they'll say yeah we want to
do the web service one
see boss OpenGL I think we're just need
version 3.3 I can't remember what all we
need here I think we're just gonna do
everything let me check what version my
computer or sports check what then of
OpenGL video art supports
Oh a new way to do this that I should
know up Tom ahead run DX day
well this is this is Harlan DirectX I
did not read that message that popped up
okay yeah I'm on HP's evoke 17g - pretty
old-school 32 gigs of RAM don't be jelly
DirectX 12 I care about is VHS tape
naive that takes its time this is not
saying anything about OpenGL I don't I
don't want to accept your cookies sued
the X died again
okay so we have a quad you're okay 20200
M
look at the specifications I guess this
should say
to be memory gddr5 oh this is also the
desktop one I'm guessing no yeah okay
opengl 4.6 ven eyes and we also have to
toe if shader model 5.1 visible the way
you need to know for how you how you set
up your programming stuff alright so I
guess I could go the latest I think the
thing I'm going to work on is in three
point three but I might just go ahead
and upgrade it to the latest and just
force everybody to have a decent video
card that uses it in case you're
wondering what glad is it's basically
like well it's like glue the old the old
extension grabber was called blue it's
like it's just a little header that
pulls in all your opengl stuff so you
just makes it easier alright so this is
good for point six weird if we're gonna
do the core and this for some reason
other work I'll go to an older version
but based on my video card this should
work for point six to be fine alright
let's do it
generate
there it is
we got a permanent I guess I'll save
that god that's too long no life
let's not save that so I think we just
drink this
it's own zip this sucker cracked all
think all we need is this glad see let's
take a look at it
first of all how many lines is it 1800
lines and yes just a loader for all that
doing GL stuff all right all we really
need to know we'll come back today
later let's get gel fw3
all right Oh 3.2.1 it sounds very nice
so I'm gonna save this and this is a
final loop in it now this is something
we're gonna have to compile and like add
to our visual studio let's just download
this point for now we'll move it later
alright it's only one Meg alright so we
got all this here so we're gonna need to
compile this I'm gonna go ahead and do
that
it's best to make four so to compile it
for our machine we're gonna go to see
make browse to the source downloads next
Jill fw3
I've done this in a minute so I think we
go here maybe we just go to the roof I
think like this is break and we're gonna
build it to we'll make a new folder
called bill
and I think that's all we're gonna do
now we're just gonna hit configure where
you want to do further business to do
out bring a Hayley hold on a second
let's go to their site check that
you know studio 19
okay we're gonna doubt kind of want to
get used to it anyway there is okay so
let's close this continue let it do its
thing here you guys ready for Visual
Studio 19 2009 teen alright yeah we are
now this is a lot of stuff they don't
care about asp.net now Python now no js'
no no I think we're only gonna just do
develop no C++ no no
no this installs some DirectX stuff
one day I'll do that not with this
computer though the Linux development no
I think all we need is just just C++
total space 3.3 70 eggs all right
install while downloading I guess this
might lag me out a little
take survey no thank you okay so it's
it's only about a gig to download and
then when installed it's gonna be over
there who said at the top this little
note file yes
2019 you might as well use stuff that's
actually supported that way you can look
at documentation everybody loves
documentation documentation spill oh
that's cool like that okay clone or
check out code open a new project open
the folder okay we're going to open a
project or solution and what we're
actually gonna be looking for is this
make thing so let's generate it for 2019
I don't think we need any special
arguments here this should be enough to
tell it everything and so to do a thing
okay I don't think I'm gonna do the
debugger nothing I'm just gonna go for
release cuz to do that way cannot climb
wall can not find oxygen okay I should
probably have doc see Jim
let's do that real quick
just do the windows 1 it's gonna run it
don't want to save it 24 minutes I can't
tax again you guys have the slowest
servers I've ever seen
do you even have servers we're gonna
dial up over there well I guess we'll
let that go I'm not gonna wait for it
though bill example bill talks I guess I
don't think I actually need very much of
this other than some thing all right
let's do it
so the next thing we do is we generate
generating done ok now we can close this
well she'll lift it up developing a well
so we're gonna go to visual studio we're
gonna open a project or solution and
we're gonna plying lfw Paolo's yes I put
it build ok and I don't remember which
one is the right one think this one
now we're gonna get some options for
different ways to build it and I want to
choose the release all right
2019 is looking great I'm gonna do
release
there's also men's size release I think
I'm just gonna do final release 64
otherwise I think I'm just gonna leave
it on all bill alright let's do it
so we'll watch it with his debugger I
think I maybe should have just hit build
that go fine alright well we're doing it
it's building seem that has any errors
fine
I'm able to start program that's
understandable because it's not
something we've run so we did get a 28
succeeded zero failed that's big it's
not need to rerun all right so that's
good think we're done there I'm gonna go
ahead and well minimize
okay so what's next we need SDLT mixer
for playing sound all right I think this
is a very similar thing we'll just go to
SDL to contract media lair there it is
2.0 we actually want I steal to mixer
[Music]
there it is Oh actually I think what I
need is to develop my libraries
okay so I gotta go back and get the
runtime library or the development
library for Visual Studio okay do it
so this one is the runtime I'm gonna
have to weep at there's the development
library the mixer library are the mixer
development yeah so over neni both of
these so I'm just gonna extract them yep
going through the motions okay wait are
these precompiled think it might be yeah
okay so there's no need to do the whole
see make and build with these and you're
ready to go so that's sort of nice
extract
there is
one just hasn't lives where's the sauce
include oh there's the clear
so that's going to be for us doing our
sound